Welcome back everyone this will be my new ms
marvel trailer video that they just dropped
it mostly focuses on her new powers from what
seem like the mega bands and how they're going
to be different from the comics and her
inhumans backstory i'll explain that and
what's actually going on with the inhumans it
also focuses a little bit more on what's going
on with the villain group so i'll talk about
them too and how this is going to tie in with
the marvel phase 4 movies in the young avengers
because even though she wasn't part of the young
avengers in the comics initially they're kind of
positioning her that way in the mcu she was part
of a different team called the champions they
were like a separate group of people who were
kind of like the young avengers but if you're
brand new to the channel i will do full episode
videos for the series when it releases it is going
to overlap a little bit with the star wars obi-wan
kenobi episodes so later in may early june we'll
be seeing a whole lot of obi-wan kenobi versus
darth vader rematch while they get started with
the ms marvel episodes marvel and star wars fans
will be eating pretty good this summer but just to
talk about her powers a little bit because they do
look a little bit different and her backstory
is different from the comics because originally
in the comics she was an inhuman her powers were
biological but they're using the nega bands and
that's why her powers look a little bit more like
green lanterns with the plasma energy constructs
they tried to make the expression of her powers
look a little bit similar to the expression of
her comic book powers she uses a couple of
those wrestling moves like she uses in the
comics when she embiggens herself they call
it m biggening in the comics it's just like
a funny term that they came up with even though i
think because of the simpsons and bigen became an
actual term in the dictionary that wasn't because
of ms marvel that was because of embiggen on
the simpsons series so you can thank them for
that a noble spirit embiggens the smallest man
never heard that word before i moved to
springfield i don't know why it's a perfectly
cromulent word in the comics she started out as
this normal girl just going to school living in
jersey city that's on the other side of manhattan
from where say like spider-man is over in queens
she was a huge fan of the avengers she was a huge
fan of captain marvel that's why you see all over
her bedroom like if you zoom in enhance on all the
clippings that she has pasted up all the posters
they're all of captain marvel and some of the
avengers most of these depictions of captain
marvel are things from the captain marvel movie or
from the original captain marvel comics that were
based on her becoming captain marvel for the first
time the funny thing about the mega bands on the
tv show is that they're actually meant to be a big
callback to the og version of captain marvel the
very first version who was a man called marvel who
did appear during the captain marvel movie in the
mcu but he was played by annette benning so they
changed the character just a little bit if you
remember annette benning's character the whole mcu
backstory for the character is that it was a cree
officer who was sent to earth to research the
tesseract and create this faster than light drive
using infinity stone energy the way most people
in the mcu right now travel around the universe
because the universe is vast it takes a long time
to get around is they use those special jump gates
oh man anyway before i was so rudely interrupted
at that time i was a federal express man so there
really aren't any faster than light ships for
normal people in the mcu right now that was the
whole mcguffin during the captain marvel movies
that they were trying to find a drive that would
allow them to travel between different galaxies
instantaneously across the universe the only way
right now to get across the universe faster than
using those jump gates which take a little bit
of time they're a little bit faster but they still
are slower than faster than light is if characters
like thanos for instance or other characters like
loki have the space stone the tesseract and they
can open portals instantly traveling between two
different points in the universe or if characters
like thor can open wormholes using things like the
bifrost which are even faster than the jump gates
but it's not an instantaneous kind of thing like
you can actually see the effect of the bifrost
wormhole opening across space as it transports
the hulk at the beginning of infinity war
the only other characters that we've seen recently
that travel faster than that are characters like
the celestials who can teleport themselves that
is meant to be instantaneous so that's almost like
faster than light but it's a slightly different
type of technology but the nega bands themselves
like these bands that you see her pull out of
here that's what we think that they are at least
they're relics from the cree empire that transform
mental energy into physical energy they might
change the way they work a little bit during the
mcu but it's part of the reason why she can create
these different mental constructs based on what
she thinks of like she thinks of these two giant
fists forming together so the nega bands help her
do that using energy instead of using her embiggen
powers like the comics the reason why marvel said
that they did her powers this way a little bit
differently is just to make them seem more cosmic
like the origin of captain marvel's powers in the
mcu the origin of monica rambeau's powers in
the mcu even though her powers seem a little
bit different monica rambeau's expression of
powers will look a little bit similar to captain
marvel's even though the way she was mutated is
going to be a little bit different with the hex
i've already done a much bigger video about monica
rambeau's powers and how she's crazy powerful just
depending on who's writing her the way her powers
work are kind of nebulous so she can either be
super powerful or just kind of powerful just
depending on who's writing the character her whole
thing is that as long as she can understand how
a type of power works she can replicate it so for
instance one of the most complex types of powers
in the mcu would be the infinity stone energy
if her human brain could figure out a way to
understand exactly how infinity stone energy works
she could replicate infinity stone energy that's
how powerful she is carol danvers captain marvel
powers are a little bit different and then she's
more like a cosmic battery like she can absorb
and redirect energy but there is a limit to
that that's why during the what if series
you see the infinity stone version of ultron
infinity ultron whatever you want to call him
able to overpower carol danvers captain marvel
there is like a maximum amount of energy that
she could theoretically absorb because kamala
khan's ms marvel character is going to cross over
with the marvel's movie captain marvel 2 what they
might do is in the mcu movies introduce other cree
characters that have ties to the original captain
marvel there were a billion different versions in
the comics some of them were biologically related
to the original marvel character annette benning's
character in the mcu they wind up fighting with
the newer versions of captain marvel at some point
so they might have a version of that going on
in the background of the captain marvel 2 movie
because mutants and x-men characters are going
to be so big during marvel phase 4 marvel phase
5 a lot of you are asking what's going to happen
to the inhumans now because they're kind of like
this separate weird group with different types
of biological powers my understanding right now
is that kevin feige will eventually address them
and it'll probably be a multiverse explainer like
you'll see versions of inhuman characters
from the comics show up from the multiverse
maybe even from that inhumans tv show but right
now i'm not expecting them to be like a really
huge focus for them in marvel phase four marvel
phase five so if they do like a larger inhumans
project or they redo the tv series with new
versions of the character that probably won't
happen for a long time one of kevin feige's big
things that he said in the past is that when it
comes to including other stuff in the canon like
other weird groups it's a situation where anything
can become canon at any time just depending on
what kind of character they need and what kind
of situation it is that's why doctor strange two
is such a big deal because it presents all these
opportunities for brief versions of multiverse
variants of all these x-men characters even
fox's fantastic four characters to show up briefly
really good example of that is patrick stewart's
professor x showing up as a variant of the one
that we saw during the fox x-men movies like
he won't be the original version from those fox
x-men movies but he'll be similar to that version
along with a lot of the other variants that
we'll see on that multiverse illuminati team
and the theory being the reason why they're
variants instead of being the actual original
versions is because one of the scarlet witches
either the variant or the mcu scarlet witch
will wind up destroying that entire illuminati
base meaning that most of those variants that
we see like the really cool versions will live
very short lives during the movie but because
they're variants you're not killing the original
versions of the characters you could always bring
those characters back played by the same actors
just as different versions of the characters
right now the rumors on the ms marvel series is
they're gonna have two different villain groups
and one is going to be a little more homegrown
and one will be a little more supernatural
i believe the two different villain groups are
supposed to be one this group of black ops armored
soldiers that you see they're supposed to be part
of a group called nice nice which is sort of like
the mcu version of ice but for superheroes super
villains they're basically responsible for dealing
with illegal immigrants in real life so like
the mcu has a version of that but that's focused
more on people with superpowers talk about moon
knight and falcon and winter soldier connections
i'm doing moon knight episodes right now they
have a grc ad in the background of moon knight
the grc is this group that we learned about during
falcon and winter soldier which is responsible for
trying to put everybody back where they came
from after they get blipped back with the
hulk's infinity gauntlet snap the group that it
seems like red dagger is supposed to belong to
i believe is called clandestine even though i
don't think that they were a villain group in
the comics i think they're just changing them
a little bit for the mcu if that's what their
name is going to be but because it seems like
she's getting her powers from the nega bands
it sounds like that's going to be a big mcguffin
and people will try to steal those from her maybe
this villain group here either way i think it's
a pretty easy assumption to make that there's
going to be some kind of post credit scene either
with nick fury connecting to secret invasion and
what's happening with the scrolls during that
and the cree and some sort of post-credit scene
like monica rambeau got on wandavision teasing
the events of captain marvel 2 and the marvels
because the artifacts that she's using to gain her
powers are probably a cree or a scroll artifact
even though i haven't done a lot of young avengers
videos recently too i think the idea is that
eventually they'll do a young avengers project
of some kind whatever they wind up calling it and
she would be part of that team because there
are several different young avengers members
or characters who could be young avengers who
have been showing up or will show up in the next
year or two but if you have any other questions
about what's going on with the way they changed
her character or what's going on with the inhumans
or other ms marvel questions just post them in the
comments below we won't get the episodes till
early june so it's going to be a little while
my full moon knight episode 2 video will post
wednesday just like normal everyone click here for
my full moon knight episode 2 trailer video and
click here for my full moon knight episode 1 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!